كما أن رئيس مجموعة الاتحاد للطيران واثق من أن التعافي على الأبواب ، وأخبرني توني دوغلاس أنه شخص متفائل عندما يتعلق الأمر بالسفر الدولي مرة أخرى في عالم الطيران ، أعتقد أنه كان العام الأكثر تحديًا في التاريخ عام 2020 ، وبصفتي شخصًا متفائلًا مولودًا ، آمل بالتأكيد أن تتحسن الأمور كثيرًا في عام 2021 وما بعده ، لكن علينا أن نكون واقعيين ، فأنت تعلم أن كوفيد جائحة لم يشهده أحد من قبل واتحاد مثله. مثال من أغسطس من العام الماضي أصبح أول شركة طيران في العالم ولا يزال اليوم أول شركة طيران في العالم نفذت اختبار 100 جهاز كمبيوتر لكل شخص في نقطة الأصل ونقطة الوصول ، لذلك لا يمكنك فعليًا الصعود على متن الطائرة إلا إذا كنا يمكن أن أؤكد لك عافيتك ، ولكن يمكنك أيضًا أن تطمئن إلى أن أي شخص آخر على متن الطائرة قد أجرى مجموعة مماثلة من الاختبارات الآن ، السؤال الذي تطرحه بالطبع ، أعتقد أنه يأخذنا إلى  xt ، إذا كان هذا
هو استعارة العام الصيني الجديد ، إذا
كان عام 2020 هو عام PCR ،
أعتقد أن عام 2021 سيكون عام اللقاح
، وبما أن اللقاح أصبح الآن
صناعيًا أكثر ،
فما بدأنا بالفعل
في رؤيته
هو الفائدة  بالطبع من
برنامج التطعيم
وأعتقد أن المضي قدمًا
سيكون جزءًا
كبيرًا من العودة إلى السفر الطبيعي من الواضح
أنك لا تزال ترى أرقامًا
مكتئبة للغاية ولكن هل ترى
أي علامة على عودة
الأرقام التي قد تعطي  يدعو أحدهم للتفاؤل
بخلاف حقيقة أننا نعلم أن
هناك لقاحًا موجودًا هنا ، لذلك في
الشهرين الماضيين رأينا
تحسنًا بطيئًا جدًا في
الوضع
من حيث عدد الركاب ، لذا أه
بمعنى واحد الخط  نسير
في الاتجاه الصحيح ولكن بالطبع
تعلم أننا نستيقظ
أه الجميع يستيقظ كل صباح
وتخبرنا وسائل الإعلام أن هناك
مشكلة في بلد آخر
كان هناك تحول في مكان آخر
وما إلى ذلك وهكذا
دواليك  lly هو هدف متحرك ، إنه
ديناميكي
للغاية بالفعل ، وأعتقد أنه من الناحية الواقعية
يمكن أن يكون هذا تحديًا بالنسبة لأفضل
جزء من عام 2021 بالكامل
حتى تأخذ اللقاحات حقًا المزيد من
السيطرة وتخلق جائحة استراحة من الحرائق جانباً
كما تنظر لأنه من الواضح أنك
أخطط الآن لهذا العام في العام المقبل
وبعد ذلك
هل ترى أن اتحادًا مربحًا
هو حقًا مربح للغاية ومربح حقًا
أنا لا أتحدث عن
مربح مضحك أه
أنا حقًا مربح في إعلانك
بالتأكيد نعم ريتشارد وأعتقد أنك
تعرف ذلك  المحللون الماليون
هناك إذا نظروا حتى إلى
منتجعاتنا لعام 2019 ، فقد كان
مبلغ 600 مليون دولار أمريكي قبل خصم الفوائد والضرائب والإهلاك ، لذا في مقابل برنامج
التحول
الذي كنا نمر به ، كنا نسير
على الطريق الصحيح
لتحقيق تحول كامل
بحلول عام 2023 ، لذلك فهمنا
أن هذا  كانت لعبة طويلة ، لم تكن
تعرف أبدًا لعبة abracadabra باللونين الأبيض والأسود ،
فقد تطلب الأمر منك معرفة
العمل الصريح
والعمل الجاد بصراحة
وإعادة تصميم كامل للأعمال  نموذج ss لقد حصل
في الطريق
ومن الواضح أنه سلبي
وإيجابي والسلبي من الواضح أن عائداتنا قد
تأثرت بشكل كبير كما
أشرت
في العام الماضي وما
زالت حاليًا
إيجابية وربما تعرف
وجهة نظرك السابقة
المبتذلة القديمة أبدًا  نهدر أزمة جيدة
أه
لقد استغلنا كل فرصة في
الأساس
لإرساء مجموعة مختلفة من
الأسس للاتحاد
وفي حين أنه من الواضح أنه لا توجد نهاية
تلوح في الأفق على الفور لنطمع فيه ،
ما زلنا واثقين من أن 2023 2024
ستكون حيث قلنا أننا سنكون